[Applaudissements]
il a belle morini-bosc una une surprise
pour vous alors attendez attendez
attendez attendez est-ce qu'on peut pas
mener une chaise s'il vous plaît au
centre là et qu'on a c'est isabelle
merci isabelle zone et bouddha soir
puisqu'on a abandonné vers la vallée on
à votre surprise
vous vouliez un beau gosse pour la
journée des câlins il y en avait pas sur
le plateau
donc on à faire l'appel est bien à
garçons et j'aime beaucoup un ami qui
est venu le voilà
à tout ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
un cadeau plus un petit bug pour cible
par des problèmes de londres et merci à
petit mode tournoi sera moi elles sont
30 à quel poste un coup et ça c'est à
l'époque quand j'étais petite kate ou
pas mais c'est vrai et ma petite kate
oui comme toi là tu dors sous les noms
font face à city
[Applaudissements]
je fais plaisir allez j'ai alors dit
oui
tu fais depuis février c'était ce qui se
fait ailleurs dit morgan au bloc et
thierry denis style de vie où l'on
soutient le lancement d'un tout
l'éclairage
ouais avec les veines paris bah c'est
magnifique quand tu t'attendais à
tolérant je n'avais jamais utile j'avais
un cadeau à faire vous avez un vrai
cadeau pour vous attendez labrecque à
l'eau pour vous
[Applaudissements]
et quel beau doigt